3 65 pilotes de toute la france qu'on
courait ce week end pour le titre de
champion de france d'auto modélisme
maxime dans le top ten des meilleurs
pilotes français en étaient pour lui ce
sport c'est une histoire de famille ça a
commencé avec mon père dans les années
80 donc voilà ça commence à dater
ensuite il ya eu mon grand frère qui a
été
il a été champion de france et a fait
des championnats d'europe il a été en
finale
ensuite j'ai pris la relève et puis
dernièrement le petit frère qui a pris
également le le relais et qui représente
bien dans ce championnat
trois catégories la standard moteur non
modifiés la thune et et les formule 1
ces bolides vont vite très vite
de 70 à plus de 100 kilomètres heure ce
qui nécessite un savoir faire certain
fossat bien rare coordination du
mouvement enfin bien sûr à quel moment
faut tourner bien accéléré et savoir
actuellement faut freiner papa séné
question d'habitude après la course
passage au contrôle technique pour
vérifier la conformité de l'engin est
validé la position du pilote
la mère de maxime et steve accompagne
souvent ces garçons et son époux en
championnat en france et à l'étranger
c'est une passion qui est très prenante
et avec beaucoup de contraintes aussi
sur le plan familial et ce qui fait que
quand on se déplace avec ses enfants et
bien on continue à être présent quand
même avec eux côté budget comptez 2 500
à plusieurs milliers d'euros
suivant le degré de passion